[Musica]
ma io oggi vi vorrei dimostrare come
sostenibilità possa fare rima con
felicità e lo farò partendo da una
considerazione da una mia considerazione
che poi non è solo mia e cioè che ognuno
debba metterci del suo ognuno di noi
nella propria quotidianità deve deve
assolutamente fare qualcosa verso la
sostenibilità si deve impegnare deve
introdurre un cambiamento perché i
grandi cambiamenti di cui parliamo tutti
ma non sono delegati a qualchedun altro
che noi vediamo non sei grandi politici
ne sentiamo parlare ogni tanto sembra
che qualcuno debba fare qualcosa e
invece dobbiamo essere noi dobbiamo
essere noi ogni giorno ogni santo giorno
se fosse stato così oggi non ci
troveremmo qui a parlare di countdown
che è tristissimo davvero sapere che c'è
un conto alla rovescia sulla nostra vita
è orrendo quindi facciamo qualcosa e da
cosa inizio se non da quello che ho
fatto io perché per dimostrare che si
può fare
si parte da dobbiamo partire da noi che
cosa succede e lo ricordava prima io
anni fa lavoravo per una grande azienda
era una manager ea un certo punto ho
siccome ero appassionata di turismo e
quindi scrivevo anche di turismo avevo
questa passione
scrivevo su qualche giornale tipo
tgcom24 e altri dedicati ai viaggi anche
alle famiglie con bambini che cosa ho
fatto
ho accettato un invito ad andare in
francia in bicicletta mi ha detto
verresti con la tua famiglia ti ho detto
bossi
volenti e volentieri però lo fa in bici
questo viaggio ha detto io in bici oddio
sono padovana quindi devo dire che sono
facilitata perché qui noi fin da piccoli
a noi ci insegnano i miei nonni in
campania mi hanno insegnato ad andare in
bicicletta quindi o
ha imparato a pedalare all'età di 45
anni quindi non mi è sembrato detto però
un viaggio è una cosa diversa forse può
essere non alla mia portata
e invece mio marito che era appunto è
sempre stato un ciclista lui lo fa per
sport per lui la bici è uno sport mi ha
detto ma no dai andiamo vediamo cosa
succede
e così abbiamo preso abbia messo in un
carrellino nostro figlio che allora
aveva tre anni
questa è una foto di un viaggio
successivo che però ci rappresenta in
danimarca nel caleno siamo andate i suoi
castelli della loira e ed è stata una
magia vi assicuro una magia in tanti
sensi perché perché in un viaggio in
bicicletta pensate si sente tutto quello
che non si sente nell'abitacolo di
un'auto
i profumi e gli odori l'odore anche di
una pioggerellina e quindi dell'erba
appena non so finisce di piovere e si
sentono il profumo dei fiori del
finocchietto della mentuccia a seconda
di dove si può andare quindi gli odori
ma si crea anche un atmosfera e del
acquista che volevo farvi cogliere con
questa foto di un viaggio successivo
perché poi l'abbiamo replicato
un'atmosfera unica tra i appunto possono
essere i membri di una famiglia i
bambini non dicono mai quanto manca
perché è questo il suggerimento che do
perché il viaggio in bicicletta il
trasferimento fa parte del viaggio
quindi non manca mai perché tutto uno
spettacolo è un'immersione nel paesaggio
cosa succede torniamo torniamo da quel
viaggio e io dico dio che bellezza ma se
questa cosa l'ho fatta io
ecco perché poi mi chiamano le di bici
che non sono certo un agonista una
sportivo non sa che è sempre lì ad
andare in palestra che deve muoversi
sempre a tutti i costi tanto questo
voglio dire ma il movimento fa bene
quindi mi muovo anch'io ho detto beh
alla portata di chiunque lo devo dire
bisogna dirlo che alla portata di tutti
e che tutti lo possono fare poi oggi
cieli bike
immaginatevi la tecnologia ci ha dato
una mano quindi anche dove non ci porta
l'allenamento alle nostre gambe dei
libri ci aiuta a farlo e allora sono
tornata e sapete quelle quel periodo in
cui eravamo tutti c'era la foga
registrare il dominio
allora l'ho fatto anch'io ho detto ba
registro viaggio in bici punto com e
l'ho fatta nel 2011 nel 2012 la vita mi
ha posto di fronte ad una scelta come
spesso accade alle donne mi hanno detto
beh se che cosa c'è
adesso tutti stabilisce a milano
stabilmente e capite la padova a milano
con un nano di quattro anni con un
marito qui ho detto no no sapete che c'è
no lascio lascia e che cosa ho fatto
sono salite in sella alla bicicletta o
aperto quel cassettino quel famoso
cassetto dove c'era questo dominio
registrato e lo sapete che c'è
che io adesso inizia ad occuparmi di
turismo che era la mia passione e in
bicicletta perché parte la bici la uso
ogni giorno e invito tutti a farlo ma
anche in vacanza con la propria famiglia
e la cosa ideale per conoscere poi il
nostro paese da lina viaggio in bici
punto com pie
come avete sentito l'oscar italiano del
cicloturismo perché da noi ci sono tante
tante vie verdi tante cose belle da
vedere in bicicletta e quindi questa
oscar italiano le vuole promuovere le
regioni devono presentare alla giuria
fatta prevalentemente di giornalisti e
poi e leggiamo la più bella d'italia
quest'anno era l'abruzzo con la bike
cost ma ciclabile lungo tutti i comuni
dal primo da martinsicuro a san salvo
della dell'abruzzo ma poi cosa è
successo
poi è successo che ho detto beh però noi
dobbiamo cambiare qualcosa quindi al di
là delle vacanze e del turismo bisogna
fare qualcosa per un impegno quotidiano
in cui le amministrazioni ci devono
aiutare allora nasce l'urbano world anci
accoglie perché ancora non c'era un
premio non c'era un qualcosa che
premiasse il comune più verde quello con
le politiche sostenibili più avanti più
all'avanguardia tra virgolette non c'è
non occorre fare chissà cosa basta
eliminare i parcheggi per le auto blu
questo ogni volta crea e genera
sicuramente dei mal di pancia archetti
cattivi umori nei commercianti che poi
scoprono invece che il commercio come a
new york sale del 50 per cento quando
nasce una ciclabile in una città ad
esempio come è stato per la
pedonalizzazione e e così succede che
poi anche quest'anno premieremo appunto
e donando 30 biciclette il 18 e di
novembre nell'assemblea generale di anci
il comune che non saprà adottato
l'incentivo chilometrico per pagare il
lavoratore che va e predilige la
bicicletta perché oggi è un po la
bicicletta è diventata questo simbolo io
sono molto contenta perché anche il
bonus ha contribuito ma anche il periodo
che ci siamo lasciati mi verrebbero dire
alle spalle in realtà ce l'abbiamo un po
a fianco ancora questo lock down che ci
rincorre ci ha fatto sentire la
necessità e riscoprire che cos'è la
bicicletta c a guardare quel mezzo in
maniera un po diversa
e allora tutti tutti che l'hanno
comprata anche nei comuni dove vi
assicuro dati ancma ne sono stati
venduti milioni di biciclette quest'anno
ma anche nei comuni dove non c'era il
bonus pc sotto i 50.000 abitanti quindi
questo vuol dire che cosa perché la bca
distanti stanziava quindi veniva
privilegiata un mezzo pubblico la bcc ha
messo in movimento scan tenuto fermi
all'aria aperta pedalare in mezzo alla
natura oppure in città lc queste città
che abbiamo visto come non mai
allora vuol dire che forse questo covip
ci ha insegnato qualcosa abbiamo
imparato qualcosa ma io lo spero perché
in realtà per questo binomio bicicletta
come vi dicevo io sostenibilità felicità
bicicletta felicità adesso per così
anche assonanza col mio libro che ho
scritto alla bici della felicità alla
bici della felicità che poi la scoperta
dell'acqua calda come quella che vi sto
dicendo oggi no la bici fa bene fa bene
per tanti motivi
fa bene lo dicono i medici previene il
movimento in bicicletta non gravando
sulle articolazioni oltretutto sulla
schiena previene le malattie
cardiovascolari
reti tutte quelle malattie legate alla
sedentarietà proviamoci
impegniamoci ogni giorno a prendere la
bicicletta fare dei chilometri chi può
farlo ovviamente perché non magari per
alcune persone può essere pericoloso e
chi non ha appunto il senso
dell'equilibrio quindi adesso questa
vuole essere un invito ma per chi ha la
bicicletta in garage o kg e qui può
pedalare iniziare a pedalare
la bici mette in mettendo in movimento
il nostro corpo ci devono umore noi
sorridiamo ecco il binomio con la
felicità sorridiamo avete mai visto uno
col buco si in bici che no non si vede è
difficile vederlo perché è proprio cc
indoor fine si chiamano così endorfine
15 leggeri ci mettono di buon umore
canticchiamo in bicicletta o dedicato un
capitolo a questo e allora che cosa fa
bene alla mente vera slepoj presidente
della federazione italiana psicologi ha
teorizzato proprio nel mio libro la bici
terapia stati d'ansia attacchi di panico
in questo la bici aiuta tantissimo
quindi ci regala felicità però noi come
siamo noi siamo strani è perché uno
diceva detto questo allora dovremmo
tutti saltare rispettarci volerci bene
che cosa succede chiamo un attimo questo
breve video e concludo
[Musica]
quando la cascina per arrestarsi
come voleva portarmi le sue strisce
calma calma maleducati incivili
[Musica]
allora vuol dire che noi siamo un po
piccola rivoli ci siamo quelli che
quando siamo a piedi e in bicicletta
inviamo contro le automobili ma quando
montiamo in automobili non possiamo
sopportare il pedone o le biciclette
perché sono un ostacolo a nostra
avanzare
allora facciamo onda anche noi qualcosa
per la nostra mente per noi stessi
usciamo da questa bipolarità come la chi
direbbe uno psichiatra uno psicologo
cerchiamo di volerci bene saliamo in
sella alle biciclette rispettiamoci
reciprocamente rispettiamo il noe
automobilista e il noe ciclista e
scopriamo che sostenibilità è la nostra
felicità e il nostro futuro
grazie a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]